[Musique]
donc atteint
yakou et ivoiriens il est arrivé à paris
au mois de janvier avec un rêve en tête
celui de devenir comptable d'abord ils
savaient pas où aller vous suit et j'ai
vu une personne de ma couleur des poux
c'est à dire un africain on m'a demandé
d'arrêter là j'ai dit que je termine
croix rouge pris en charge par la croix
rouge yakou est logée à l'hôtel pendant
trois jours le temps de passer son
évaluation sociale il affirme avoir 16
ans mais sans papiers seuls les
autorités françaises peuvent déterminer
après une brève enquête sa minorité réel
on m'a posé des question j'ai répondu et
après on m'a dit d'aller dormir à
l'hôtel et après il me dit dépassé à 14
heures le résultat du test une
évaluation capitale car elle celle son
parcours
les jeunes passent un entretien
d'environ une heure avec les autorités
départementales
s'ils sont reconnus mineurs ils sont
pris en charge par l'aide sociale à
l'enfance sinon ils sont livrés à eux
mêmes on m'a dit que je t'ai notifié que
la
présence yankees par économie n'est
qu'il fallait qu'ils fassent leur écoute
a dit qu'il fallait que nombreux maîtres
du monde et moi je je je je fais
le chum de la méditerranée sommet
documents pour espérer être reconnus
mineure il ya coûts doit saisir le juge
pour enfants une procédure longue
pendant laquelle de nombreux jeunes
isolés se retrouvent à la rue
c'est dans ce campement au nord-est de
paris que yakou passe ses nuits depuis
la mi janvier
ce tunnel abrite environ 120 personnes
dont 80 mineurs isolés étrangers
yasmine est l'une des bénévoles
apportant une aide sociale médicale et
juridique à ces jeunes ils sont
considérés unicom ni comme mineur ni
comme majeur donc en fait on les appelle
les minis sont dans un flou juridique
qui fait que finalement ils se
retrouvent isolés
seuls les plus chanceux d'entre eux sont
placés à l'hôtel avec l'aide
d'associations
mohamed est arrivé en france en août
2000 21 de guinée conakry il dit avoir
16 ans il est aussi en recours pour sa
minorité et logent dans un hôtel à la
défense depuis septembre 2021 c'est
provisoire donc il faudrait pas mettre
en tête que c'est définitif donc achat
point cela je pense avoir jeudi à
peut-être que si ça se passe bien je dis
je remercie mais par contre là je ne
sais pas quoi faire j'ai cette
inquiétude parce que je sais que quand
je dormais dur site est prévue pour mai
la vie je trouvais des endroits mais
c'était très difficile c'était partout
et même la vie les habits heureusement
qu'on est là bas je me sens mieux après
un parcours difficile de nombreux jeunes
souffrent de troubles psychiques
renforcée par la vie dans la rue à
laquelle il n'était pas habitué
vivre en communauté peut être source de
tensions ils sont très nombreux dans les
chambres savez pour les hôtels mais
parfois ils peuvent se retrouver jusqu'à
7 par chambre est quelqu'un qui a des
troubles du sommeil qui fait des
cauchemars qui se sent pas bien qu'il
perdu confiance oscillant l'autre parce
que il a subi des tortures de la
maltraitance être tout le temps tout le
temps comme ça en grand groupe avec pas
forcément des personnes qui l'a choisi
il ya des tensions il ya quand même
beaucoup de tension entre eux outre des
chambres insalubres médecins sans
frontières dénonce aussi un manque de
suivi médical social et éducatif de la
part de l'état et alerte les traffics
sont positionnés à proximité des
hébergements hôteliers quand vous avez
un jeune qui l'a plus de perspectives
parce qu'on la plaçait dans cet hôtel il
n'a pas vu son travailleur social il a
une dette qu'il a accumulées sur le
parcours migratoire ou alors il souhaite
travailler pour aider financièrement sa
famille et que rien ne lui est proposé
et que par contre en face on a des
personnes mal intentionnées qui peuvent
proposer certaines choses c'est aussi
les positions dans une situation assez
périlleuse fixe une nouvelle loi
relative à la protection des enfants a
été promulguée le 7 février 2022 pour
les mineurs isolés étrangers pris en
charge par l'aide sociale à l'enfance le
placement à l'hôtel sera désormais
interdit d'ici 2024 bénédicte pétel
député la république en marche a
travaillé sur cette loi pendant
plusieurs années si on interdit du jour
au lendemain les enfants risquent de se
retrouver à la rue donc c'est juste pour
cette raison-là condé on accorde une
dérogation de deux mois pendant deux ans
je suis bien consciente que c'est pas
l'idéal je suis allé dans des hôtels
j'ai vu dans quelles conditions vivaient
les enfants et des conditions qui sont
pas idéales
qui sont pas acceptables même mais
parfois il faut laisser le temps au
département de trouver une solution
l'une des solutions soutenues par les
associations et de créer des centres
d'hébergement réservé aux mineurs non
accompagnés ont recours sur le modèle du
centre emile zola à paris créée par la
mairie en décembre 2020 il accueille
quarante jeunes
une goutte d'eau les ong estiment qu
environ 3000 mineurs isolés étrangers
dorment dans la rue tous les jours